it's time for drew's news the only news
that wonders how you've been all summer
and with me at the desk
this season the co-pilot of my news
dreams rossi ross
matthews we're
back i have missed you so much and what
a way to kick off season two drew i mean
i was a girl alone in a box until you
came and rescued me ross oh
i was your knight in shining armor are
my knight in shining armor or like night
in sequence but i'll take it thank you
drew true true true all right we're
gonna jump right in with this epic movie
news apparently everyone in hollywood is
starring in don't look up and it's the
new movie by adam mckay adam mckay has
done everything vice anchorman
big short yes he's a genius um the
trailer is out now and variety reports
that leonardo dicaprio is so hot and
jennifer lawrence also so hot star as
two astronomers trying to save the world
from total destruction
it's a reality movie
um thank god just kidding it's not it's
fictional take a look
there's a comment headed directly
towards earth do you know how many the
world is ending meetings we've had over
the last two years drought famine hole
in the ozone is so boring
i mean meryl streep is the freaking
president
uh
meryl streep you got my vote thank you
so much i i want her to be the president
for real i know secretary of state diane
keaton i'll take it absolutely diane
please come on this show we are i mean
please we we stalk her we stand diane
keaton i mean hello hello
you look like the annie hall of fame
right now
miss diane keaton please take my hand in
fashion marriage
and please grace us with your presence
god we love her so much and guess what
why we have more good news ross oh yeah
so jennifer lawrence did you hear this
uh should people report she's got a bun
in the oven and it's not sourdough she
is expecting her first child with her
husband art gallery director
cook maroney
i love her so much and do you know what
what you call it when a pregnant
jennifer um lawrence has cravings
hunger games
[Laughter]
you know what um no don't clap
i have a story about jennifer laura tell
me everything okay i was at lunch with
her
me and cameron diaz so we're in the
restaurant and um
we see this guy outside and
he looks like a paparazzi and um he's on
a moped and he's got cameras and we're
like oh we're all in the restaurant and
we you know we just showed up looking
crappy and we're all just like oh god
it's that moment
and um we're like you know what let's
just go out and uh he was a nature
photographer had no interest in us
and boy did we feel stupid
and it was hilarious that we all just
had a big laugh at our own expense oh i
love that you're like oh he
he doesn't care at all about the three
of us he is a bird watcher i know but he
missed like the best picture ever can
you imagine
wow okay
i'm very interested to get your take on
this next story rossi because a new
study from the american institute of
physics found that heterosexual women
consistently rated men who speak less
clearly are more attractive
what what what
the mumbling got these ladies motors a
rumbling
and now previous science found that
straight men on the other hand were more
attracted to women who clearly speak and
enunciate
you heard me oh i heard you we're gonna
get
tonya's take who is right here in the
audience
and you say that you love a mumbling man
tanya
yes i do actually and he's sitting next
to me
[Applause]
so okay um what was the draw other than
the mumbling he was trying to ask me out
he was mumbling and i found it very cute
and attractive i felt like he was kind
of shy and some sensitive side in him
for some reason
three years later he asked me to marry
him he proposed and he mumbled again
can you do an impression how did he do
it well he couldn't say it but he wrote
it down in a little note and he gave me
some roses and he had the ring and then
he's like would you marry me baby that's
what i said on the note and i clearly
understood that's what he was asking
gus
why do you think that you just are so
darn charming
well first of all like i was really
nervous because she's so beautiful and
you know i just got i just started
uh mumbling and i couldn't get it right
and so when i wanted to ask her to marry
me i was like i'm gonna mumble again and
so i wrote it down just in case so that
she can get the message
and thank you tanya and gus this was so
fun it's our first official news in
hollywood i know and we got an audience
thank you guys
[Music]